[Applause]
foreign
for losing weight a zepik's grand but
you'll also lose your wedding band
you've heard of Oz epic it was created
to help diabetes patients control their
blood sugar but took off thanks to its
side effect of rapid weight loss or what
we call the Pompeo effect
I'm not
anyway people have posted all over
social media about it including several
celebrities um
sweeping the nation called ozepik finger
and unlike some rapidly spreading
diseases this one didn't originate in a
Chinese lab or Hunter Biden's groin
need a better word than groin
get on that cat basically women who are
on the weight loss drug are discovering
that their fingers and wrists are
getting skinnier than ever making it
more likely that their jewelry will fall
off which would Rob them of the
experience of having it stolen from them
at gunpoint
in fact the number of women going to
Jewelers to get their wedding ring size
down is reportedly way up from last year
and if that's not legit cold hard data
illustrating this so zepik finger Trend
I don't know what is
at any rate Anthony fauci recommends we
still wear masks
at least to protect against flying cubic
zirconia
when doctors were asked if Rings were
falling off of men too they said yes but
for some reason it doesn't bother them
men are pigs am I right it's funny
because men cheat on their wives I know
you go girl I wonder who the men are
cheating with though yes
oh yeah their wife's best friend yeah
Vanderpump
so cat um this is interesting what do
you make of this I am becoming this
whole Oz epic thing just exploded
because it really does sound like it's
the miracle drug everybody was waiting
for because nobody likes to exercise
nobody likes to eat healthy this allows
you to do both except doesn't it sap the
joy out of life because you don't want
to eat it all
no there's other things about life that
are joyful besides eating I mean I know
you're shocked to hear that from me
there's no such thing as a shortcut I
feel like you would maybe want to be
concerned about some of the other
effects but also I think it's because
celebrities talk about it whenever
celebrities or there's rumors of
celebrities doing something people are
like oh she did it she's fine except
celebrities they can have like just
doctors come to their house I would love
that I would love to be so famous and
Rich that I could call a doctor and be
like have them tell me that I'm not
dying yeah that's a normal thing to want
right
I feel a little dizzy it's okay right
yeah that's all right it's really easy
to get a doctor to come to your house
just like make some weird psychological
threat to somebody
or what it's called a concierge doctor
oh yeah they come to your house yeah
I've got one let me oh very very yeah I
manage my wrestling money right yeah so
let me fiscally responsible hence
Republican yes
you
all of this stuff you know medications
pretty well why are you what is it about
ozepik that we're not seeing
well fat fingers for one yeah
[Applause]
I mean Greg this you broke this here yes
you're not gonna Brett Bear didn't get
this one yo
people taking a drug that makes you lose
weight and your fingers get skinny oh my
God
you would think if you had fat fingers
and you lost it and you walked in with
your hula hoop and ring then it would be
a happy day for you my rings down four
sizes since I started working out it's a
humble brag yeah oh I lost my finger
problem like
because the cold part is they lose the
weight on their wrists and their fingers
but not their belly so I guess that's
you get what you wish they do don't they
don't they lose in their belly I don't
know Greg I do it the old-fashioned way
I overeat go out gotta go to the gym
work it off then I get it off and go go
let's go eat and I go gotta do it again
so you know I don't like needles so I
couldn't do those yeah you gotta you
gotta inject it once but again it's one
of those things where cats write
shortcuts never work short term because
here's the cold part once they get the
little ring fixed once they get off it
guess what yeah bad fingers are back
yeah and the ring don't fit and that's
when the guys say honey that's why I
wasn't wearing it
fat fingers you know you love that punk
band Yes you know Kennedy I I posited
this theory that that ozepik would have
been a better vaccine than the covet
vaccine which is a low bar because if
you low if you if you slim people down
that was like the major risk factor
aside from age for covid you could have
like saved more lives if you just pumped
them full of ozempic I mean but where
are we in society when we're all about
body positivity and if you weigh 600
pounds you're supposed to be a hero for
flying in a coach seat and taking up
three seats and making other people
uncomfortable but at the same time we're
obsessed with easy weight loss I we we
have no idea who we are or what is
important to us but anyone who loses
weight you know they call it a Olympic
face ozympic ass ozemic finger when you
lose weight especially when you lose
weight quickly you lose weight in all
parts of your body and if you don't have
muscle your ass sags yes you know
Catherine denove famously said you have
to choose between your face and your ass
oh so and that's you know you can't have
that don't do it
don't don't do it I was thinking the
same telling you now
this is a preemptive strike stay away
all right
he's going to do it no it's passing it's
passing there it goes all right
don't do it Congressman won't throw this
building
it's been
my face or my ass
[Applause]
I don't even think welcome to the show
what do you what do you do to exercise
what do you do do you uh do you find a
challenge because when you're a
congressman you're always going around
you eat you you eat everywhere you have
to eat corn dogs and bears secret gym
yeah oh I had a secret gym well no I
think in uh for me it's just a lot of a
lot of Weights yeah I hate running so I
just lift weights all the time it's my
time and not answer my phone get away
from everybody it's a great time
actually yeah
um what concerns me are the guys who
like run for like for president and for
governor all of a sudden they lost 20
pounds what happened yeah and now I see
it's the Olympic finger thing yeah I
know lizzo's really mad about this is
she taking three shots at one time
sorry lizzo sorry shots of whipped cream
yes
but no I like you know I just want to
make sure like my shirt buttons don't
exactly so I'm staying there I'm good
there yeah yeah yeah I'm trying to stay
plump yeah I think my wife likes it I'm
staying there
we call it staying frame yes
we're saying we're on our frame all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else